wow when you lose chalk tud
you are in trouble that's like your wife
testifying against you in court dana
like that's like that's like you just
turn on his family chalk tud
i think that i see a possible character
on the exclamation point tud is the
greatest name i've ever come up with i
think it's pretty good pretty good so
the chaos that biden is experiencing
right now is exactly what he campaigned
against right right so he was supposed
to be the steady hand on the wheel and
um he was gonna be boring right
especially on foreign policy everything
remember he gave the speech on february
4th america is back um now we have this
absolute mess in afghanistan we just
showed you what's happening on the
border and our oldest ally france is
calling us names that they used to
reserve just for president trump exactly
so things are not exactly going well the
best thing i guess for the biden
administration when all this came down
it was late on a friday but the thing is
is that um the president wanted to right
the ship
by giving a speech on covet boosters and
then it turns out that he got he put the
cart in front of the horse who heard
that one
and yes and so now he's going to try to
give a climate speech tomorrow right in
the meantime all these other things are
happening but biden's political erosion
prevents the democrats from taking it to
the republicans on the debt ceiling or
for the democrats to get any traction on
its legislative agenda which is
completely falling apart before our eyes
i love how you worked in erosion after
talking about climate change that's why
you sit there
right i think i don't know that's the
best planet yeah so you didn't plan that
i thought that dagon um here's my theory
the only reason the media is calling
this stuff out is because they have no
choice they're kind of backed into a
corner here they they thought they could
drag joe across the finish line but they
can't anymore so now they're just
letting him drop right they and they
will talk about credibility
well
why weren't you talking about that when
joe biden stood up in front of the
american people
during the disastrous afghanistan
withdrawal and said al qaeda's not in
afghanistan anymore oh and americans can
get to the airport in kabul and our
allies are with us this is just they the
body administration
joe at all they stand up and just lie
over and over again and act like
we don't know the truth or can see the
truth so cnn had a full screen of all of
the issues this morning
like rebuke of immigration
um bill the in the list it's under biden
headaches
so the crisis at the texas bridge that
sounds like there is like a big pothole
on the bridge that needs some quick
creek put into
so and or these civilians the drone
strike kills civilians under headache no
a headache is putting together this
seating chart for your daughter's
wedding right these are disasters let's
call it what it is they're looking
through a political lands like oh this
must be really hard for our favorite guy
but it's like no this is actual
tragedies crimes and justice going on
jessica as uh america is no you are with
child we won't get into the effects on
the climate
of me overpopulating yes
but when your child is born how will you
explain to him or her why you voted to
jo voted for joe biden
we have cuter swag on the democratic
side she'll be in her little
gender reveal but it must be hard for
you i
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
by comparison i mean yeah
i'm dwarfish we'll talk about
i will talk about joe biden's problems
now uh
so chuck todd i feel like when people
use them as an example it's like when
people hold up jennifer rubin and they
say like conservatives are turning on
trump like chuck todd loves to play the
both sides game um but they're
definitely
long the headaches are bad and the drone
strike even though this does happen
regularly and it has since you know the
mid-2010s
when you hear seven kids
passed away and there were no isis k
fighters gotten for that that is
something that i think can stick with
you not necessarily bring down an
administration but that's something that
does stand out on the list of like not a
normal headache yeah no it's pretty bad
it's pretty bad and would i
there has to be something we could do
for their families whether it means
bringing them here seems like the only
right thing to do jesse the un
is meeting this week which raises the
question why
it's a good question i'm thinking
traffic so i'm gonna have to make plans
but
i was thinking joe's now just instead of
fixing problems he's creating problems
and little jesse jr picked his head out
of the crib today and he said you know
dad the only thing
joe biden knows how to fix is elections
i said jesse jr
what show have you been watching he said
dad i'm watching the king of late night
i said who kimmel
oh i know he said exclamation point but
it's true he what he does
i mean at least the economy is good
right tegan
did you see the market today i think
that field lost 16 million
although all the wage gains are getting
wiped out by inflation and now his
spending bill as xana said is hanging in
the bounce he's taking orders from the
taliban we're getting
bites into smithereens by the russians
the cartel controls our border he can't
even get on the phone to the allies and
say hey guys heads up on the pipeline or
the nuke sub deal or he can't even be
bothered to do that and the guy has no
juice with our enemies either mexico
says no on the border iran said no on
the nuke deal opec said no one no more
oil production
who says yes to joe
the chef at the white house no one says
yes to joe and then the ap comes out and
they say joe biden is suffering from
some setbacks
as if setbacks are something you can
catch like a cold like oh yeah he's got
a case of the setbacks don't worry about
that
this is how the people feel greg let me
speak for the people people feel like we
just signed a quarterback who can't run
or throw
and the season just started you know
what you know what you uh you uh compet
it's an inverse of setbacks every time
something small happened under the trump
administration the world was exploited
the world was chaos and then when
something actually big happens here it's
just a separate
setback
take two and call us in the morning
exactly hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else